So, you've already binged The Mandalorian.
Now what?
If you're still wondering whether or not to
stick by the House of Mouse, we've got you
covered.
Here's your comprehensive rundown of all the
exciting original shows and movies being produced
exclusively for Disney+ in 2020.
The Mandalorian: Season 2
This is the big one.
The Mandalorian and Baby Yoda stormed the
internet when Disney+ launched in November
of 2019, and the show seemed to hit that sweet
spot of mainstream success and obsessive fandom
that made it a must watch.
A second season of the show was obvious - what's
surprising is how quickly we'll be able to
sit down and watch it.
As soon as the season finale debuted in December,
showrunner Jon Favreau revealed that the second
season of The Mandalorian is slated to arrive
in fall 2020.
The show debuted on November 12, 2019, so
the follow-up arriving a year later seems
like a pretty good bet.
There were quite a few cliffhangers left over
at the end of The Mandalorian's first season.
We and the characters don't know much real
information about Baby Yoda, and all signs
point to the second season focusing on the
search for the child's home.
There's also still the threat of Moff Gideon
- and his Darksaber - to deal with.
WandaVision
One of the two original MCU shows coming to
Disney+ in 2020, WandaVision looks to be a
bit of a strange one.
The series focuses on Wanda Maximoff a.k.a.
Scarlet Witch, and her late android lover
Vision, who up until now was maybe the deadest
character in the entire MCU.
As for how he's back, or what they'll be up
to, that's anyone's guess.
So far, the imagery we've seen from WandaVision
evokes a particularly strange Leave it to
Beaver vibe.
Paul Bettany reportedly told an audience at
the D23 expo that the show would have old
school sitcom vibes with some serious darkness
hidden just below the surface.
Some familiar faces from the MCU will appear
along the way, including Darcy Lewis, Jimmy
Woo, and an all-grown-up Monica Rambeau, now
played by Teyonah Parris.
We're intrigued to see what will bring them
all together.
Considering where the MCU appears to be headed
with some of its post-Infinity Saga releases,
it's been theorized that WandaVision will
serve as a way to introduce supernatural and
horror elements into the greater MCU.
Guardians of the Galaxy did something similar
with cosmic concepts on its original release,
and Doctor Strange opened the door for mysticism
to find its way into the franchise.
It'll be interesting to see what types of
risks Marvel and Disney take with Wanda's
reality-bending powers post-Endgame.
"I don't even know who you are."
"You will."
Falcon and the Winter Soldier
The second MCU show hitting Disney+ this year
is Falcon and the Winter Soldier.
We've got a few details on this one, but the
showrunners have generally played it pretty
close to the chest.
Anthony Mackie and Sebastian Stan will be
reprising their title roles, and a lot of
the other cast has been revealed as well.
Daniel Bruhl is returning as Captain America:
Civil War’s Helmut Zemo.
Emily VanCamp will reprise her role as Sharon
Carter.
Wyatt Russell, meanwhile, joins the cast as
John Walker, a.k.a. U.S. Agent.
Falcon and the Winter Soldier is slated to
consist of six episodes that will release
weekly, rather than all at once - a strategy
Disney+ seems to be favoring for all of its
original series.
With director Kari Skogland at the helm for
every episode, the show looks to follow in
the vein of the Captain America films, playing
like a spy thriller.
It will focus on Sam Wilson adapting to his
role as the new Captain America following
the events of Avengers: Endgame.
Star Wars: The Clone Wars Season 7
Star Wars: The Clone Wars, set during the
time between Attack of the Clones and Revenge
of the Sith, originally debuted in 2008 as
a feature film that served as a pilot for
the animated series.
The show then ran for five seasons on Cartoon
Network before being cancelled, with 13 leftover
episodes eventually hitting Netflix as a makeshift
sixth season.
But there were still scripts left unproduced
and plot threads left dangling.
Fans kept hope alive, and their campaigning
was finally rewarded when a definitive seventh
and final season was announced for Disney+.
A trailer released in January 2020 teased
the revival's thrilling return to the storylines
fans have been waiting to see concluded for
years - the romance of Anakin and Padme, the
moral struggle of the clone soldiers, and
a climactic showdown between Ahsoka Tano and
Darth Maul.
It's a miracle revival that fans have been
waiting for; the wait finally ends on February
21st.
Muppets Now
The Muppets are coming to Disney+ in 2020,
but not in the format you might expect.
Muppets Now will feature celebrity guests
and is being touted as an unscripted series,
but there aren't a ton of details available
outside of that.
The promise of celebrity guests suggests that
the project could resemble the original Muppet
Show variety series from the 1970s, but we'll
have to wait for more details to learn more.
The Muppets last had a show on ABC in 2015,
following a pair of feature films in 2011
and 2014.
These iterations were largely dedicated to
playing on the nostalgia of adults who grew
up with the characters.
Time will tell if Muppets Now represents a
fresh retooling for a streaming audience,
but regardless, it will be a welcome return
to the spotlight.
The Phineas and Ferb Movie: Candace Against
the Universe
Phineas and Ferb, a cartoon series that ran
from 2007 through 2015, is the story of two
brothers who are constantly inventing extraordinary
ways to pass time during their summer vacation.
Their sister, Candace, is always trying to
get them in trouble, and their pet platypus
moonlights as a James Bond-esque spy, constantly
thwarting the villainous plans of Dr. Doofenshmirtz.
Pretty standard stuff.
The original creators are returning for a
feature film called The Phineas and Ferb Movie:
Candace Against the Universe.
According to Disney's official announcement
at D23 in 2019, the plot will feature the
two brothers traveling across the galaxy to
rescue their sister.
The Phineas and Ferb Movie: Candace Against
the Universe will reportedly release in the
summer of 2020, though an official date has
yet to be announced.
Lizzie McGuire
While there have been some behind-the-scenes
shake-ups during production, as far as we
know, we can still expect a full season of
the Lizzie McGuire reboot in 2020.
"Hi!
It's me."
Hilary Duff is confirmed to return in the
title role, with much of her supporting cast
expected to be on board as well.
The new Lizzie McGuire was set to kick off
with Lizzie's 30th birthday in New York City,
where she would be seen working as an interior
design apprentice.
However, Variety reports that show creator
Terri Minsky parted ways with the reboot after
only two episodes were filmed.
According to a Disney spokesperson,
"After filming two episodes, we concluded
that we need to move in a different creative
direction and are putting a new lens on the
show."
The show was supposed to release this year,
and possibly still will - we just don't have
further details yet.
Monsters at Work
Get some more Pixar in your life with Monsters
at Work.
This series is a direct sequel to Monsters,
Inc., picking up six months after the 2001
film.
It will introduce a new character, Tylor Tuskmon,
who graduates as the top scarer in his college
class.
He comes to work at Monsters, Inc. on the
day the company switches over from scares
to laughter, leaving him unsure how to move
forward.
Much of the Monsters movies' all-star cast,
including John Goodman and Billy Crystal,
will reunite for the series, with Tylor being
played by Ben Feldman, known for his work
on Mad Men, Silicon Valley, and more.
"I just wanna be a part of this place.
I think it's on the way up."
There's no official release date yet for Monsters
at Work, but Disney has announced that we
can expect it this year.
Chip 'n' Dale
You might remember these two cartoon chipmunks
from the 1989-90 Rescue Rangers cartoon, but
Chip and Dale have been around much longer
than that.
They originally appeared as troublemakers
in classic Disney animated shorts starting
in the 1940s, frequently antagonizing Donald
Duck or Pluto.
Disney+ has plans for the chipmunk duo, and
is rebooting Chip 'n' Dale in that classic
cartoon philosophy.
The new cartoon will be comprised of 39 short
episodes of about seven minutes each.
It will feature mostly situational, nonverbal
comedy focusing on the life of the two characters
surviving in the big city.
There's no set release date yet, but we do
know Chip 'n' Dale is coming at some point
in 2020.
Until then, go watch the 1952 short "Pluto's
Christmas Tree" on Disney+ to see what these
Chipmunks are all about.
*chipmunk noises* *nut throw* *Pluto bark*
Star Wars: Jedi Temple Challenge
Remember Legends of the Hidden Temple and
Guts?
If you've got fond memories of those kid competition
shows, you might want to keep your eyes peeled
for Star Wars: Jedi Temple Challenge.
It's a live action skills-based game show
set in the Star Wars universe.
It's also set to be hosted by Ahmed Best,
who portrayed Jar Jar Binks in the prequel
trilogy.
Jedi Temple Challenge will test contestants'
skills in three different settings: a forest
planet, a star cruiser, and a Jedi temple.
According to Dan Silver, Vice President of
Disney Original Unscripted Content,
"Star Wars: Jedi Temple Challenge brings together
the best of Star Wars - competitive spirit,
harrowing obstacles and a hero's triumph over
challenges - in a totally new format for the
franchise."
It's a bit of an odd one, but Star Wars: Jedi
Temple Challenge could be pretty fun - it's
hard to tell until the release gets closer,
and as of now, there's no concrete release
date other than some time in 2020.
Stargirl
Based on Jerry Spinelli's novel of the same
name about nonconformity and romance in high
school, Stargirl is set to arrive on Disney+
on March 13, 2020.
It's the story of high schooler Leo, who is
awestruck by a new student, Susan "Stargirl"
Caraway.
Stargirl is unique, interesting, and refuses
to conform to teen social norms, causing much
of the school to turn against her.
Leo, however, falls in love with her.
At Stargirl's center is the acting debut of
Grace VanderWaal, a 15-year-old singer-songwriter
who won America's Got Talent in 2016.
VanderWaal had massive charisma and stage
presence during her run on America's Got Talent,
so it'll be fun to see her in an acting role.
As an added bonus, she'll be displaying her
singing and ukulele skills as well.
Be Our Chef
The runaway popularity of cooking competition
shows in recent years has been hard to miss,
so it's no surprise that Disney+ has one on
the way in 2020.
Be Our Chef will feature two families competing
each week to create Disney-themed dishes that
fit in the confines of that week's challenge,
with the winning team's final dish being turned
into a treat that will actually served at
Walt Disney World.
"We invite you to relax.
Let us pull up a chair as the dining room
proudly presents your dinner."
Be Our Chef is hosted by Angela Kinsey, who
is probably best known for playing Angela
on the U.S. version of The Office.
Kinsey now hosts a YouTube cooking show with
her husband, Baking with Josh and Ange.
Further details about Be Our Chef, including
an exact premiere date, are yet to be announced,
but we can expect the competition to arrive
on Disney+ at some point this year.
Short Circuit
No, this has nothing to do with Johnny-5.
Instead, Short Circuit sounds like it could
be a really fun way to discover new talent
in the animation world.
Short Circuit is a short film project that
Disney began back in 2016, purportedly allowing
anyone at Walt Disney Animation Studios the
chance to pitch their own ideas for potential
production with the full support of the studio.
The project opens the door for potentially
risky, unique, or offbeat stories that might
not otherwise have been told.
14 different short films will debut with Short
Circuit's premiere on Disney+ at the end of
January.
Disney has showed off a few of these films
at various expos and trade shows, like "Just
a Thought," "Exchange Student," and "Jing
Hua."
It looks like each film will vary wildly in
tone and animation style, and it might be
fun to see some undiscovered talent at Disney
work their magic.
Lamp Life
If you saw Toy Story 4 and were confused about
how Bo Peep wound up where she did, "Lamp
Life" has got you covered.
The story was originally conceived as a flashback
that would appear in the film, but it was
eventually cut for time and pacing issues.
Instead, it's been reworked into the short
film "Lamp Life," premiering on Disney+ at
the end of January.
"Lamp Life" will reveal how Bo Peep made the
journey from Andy's family to Second Chance
Antiques.
It will feature a few familiar voices from
the Toy Story films, including Annie Potts
as Bo Peep; Emily Davis as Billy, Goat, and
Gruff; and Ally Maki as Giggle McDimples.
"Lamp Life" is directed by Valerie LaPoint,
who has directed a few other Pixar short films
and was a writer on Toy Story 4.
Choosing to release "Lamp Life" as its own
short film instead of an extra alongside Toy
Story 4 seems to indicate that it's been fleshed
out quite a bit.
Pixar fans will definitely want to check it
out.
Timmy Failure: Mistakes Were Made
Based on the Timmy Failure book series by
Stephan Pastis, Timmy Failure: Mistakes Were
Made is a film about a young boy who runs
a detective agency in Portland, Oregon.
One day, Timmy's "Failuremobile," a Segway
his mother won in a contest, is stolen, and
Timmy sets out to crack the case with his
partner.
By the way, Timmy's partner is an imaginary
1,500-pound polar bear.
Judging from the trailer, Timmy Failure: Mistakes
Were Made looks like a fun cross between Encyclopedia
Brown and Calvin & Hobbes.
Considering the source material, the film
could launch a whole family-friendly franchise
if it's successful.
We'll find out how it goes - and hopefully,
who took the Segway - when it hits Disney+
on February 7, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.